okay today I'm going to talk to you
about recycling I'm going to talk to you
about three different aspects of
recycling and why it's so important
because earth's resources won't last
forever
they're finite so it's really important
to be able to recycle so they can last
much longer so the first reason why it's
important to recycle is the idea that it
conserves resources now like I
previously said the amount of material
materials in the world is finite which
means one day that it will run out it's
not unlimited so let's just think about
this let's say we're extracting
aluminium from beneath the earth's
surface every single time we extract
some aluminium from from any Thea
surface we get less and less there's
less and less left so the more and more
that we extract the less and less
missing raw materials we have left
because there's a finite amount that
just means they're limited so instead of
doing this if we if we recycle materials
then those raw materials beneath a
surface or wherever we're going to be
extracting them will last much longer
also if we recycle it requires much less
energy than constantly having to extract
these metals for example the extraction
of aluminium is very expensive because
we have to use electrolysis so there's
one really big reason why it's important
to recycle the second reason is the fact
that it protects the environment and
environment so as we can see let's think
about this this idea here when we
extract metals from the ground we need
to we need to mind for them so when
we're mining for them it can it can
basically destroy habitats so animals
might have been living in this area and
then we built this mine and the habitats
have been destroyed so that's one reason
why recycling instead of building loads
of mine
and extracting it from the ground is a
positive thing also we need to consider
landfill sites so a landfill site is
quite simply where we go and dump loads
and loads of our rubbish that we throw
away rather than recycling so you know
trucks Laureus might take all of this
all of this waste here and just dump it
in these huge piles it's called a
landfill
now landfill is bad for the environment
because first of all it takes up loads
of space and secondly it can really
pollute the environment which is put
into so there protect the environment is
another reason why you can recycle
because if we're recycling for reusing
and reforming products we don't have to
dump it into these huge landfill sites
now the final one I'm going to talk
about the final advantage of recycling
to talk about is economic benefits so
economics is to do with money so it's
actually a good way to be able to to
generate money or save money because if
we recycle we're doing a couple of
things first of all we can have lots of
people employed there's jobs made
available secondly we don't have to
spend loads and loads of money on
extracting our raw materials for example
less less money if I was extracting
aluminium would have to be spent on
electrolysis if we can just reuse it
we're saving lots and lots of money also
we can create new products we can create
recycled products and if we if we sell
those products again we can make money
from them rather than just chuck it into
a landfill site where we can know well
they're no longer be used if they could
be turned into something new we can then
sell those new things and we can
generate more money so just to summarize
there's three big reasons why it's
important to recycle first
for conserving resources which are
finite which means one day they'll run
out protecting the environment from
building mines and landfill and finally
economic benefits by creating jobs
saving money on extracting raw materials
and being able to sell those recycled
products thank you very much